we're here at the bloomberg power
players summit in los angeles talking to
some industry experts about sports
betting
ubiquitous gambling at the touch of a
screen is changing how people engage
with their favorite teams and it's not
just about betting on the outcome of the
game
it's not just about
who's going to win the game what's the
over under
you know it's about who's going to score
the first touchdown and who's going to
be the mvp some states you can actually
bet on the coin toss and
the length of the national anthem
and what you're seeing is you know this
has become a part of how the live sports
consumer really engages with with sports
a host of states have legalized it since
2018 when the supreme court overturned a
federal ban on sports wagering
more than 100 million americans now live
in places where they can legally bet on
events like the super bowl
is there some time after the band that
you think you can really pinpoint and
say that's what changed everything
because not everyone jumped on the
bandwagon right away and was ready to
embrace sports betting but like now it
seems like they are
the role that fantasy sports has played
in legalizing online sports betting if
you go back to 2016 they actually passed
the uh the law to legalize fantasy
sports and that really provided a bridge
to 2018.
[Music]
a lot of the lobbyists that were helping
to legalize fantasy sports quickly moved
over with actually fanduel and
draftkings
it's only been a few years since you've
had legal sports betting outside of
nevada
14 states right now that you can legally
place a bet on that's up from 10 a year
ago
within weeks of gambling apps being
introduced in new york on january 8 this
year betting companies had signed up 1.5
million accounts from 1.1 million
customers almost 90 percent of them new
to regulated sports betting
i think also a big deal was that the
attitudes of the leagues and the other
you know stakeholders associated with
the games changed i remember when adam
silver wrote an op-ed i believe it was
in the times talking about you know how
sports betting should be legalized and
regulated and it was like wow
a commissioner of a major sports league
is saying that it was just unheard of
the nfl has said it expects to reap one
billion dollars a year from its deals
with sports betting companies by the end
of the decade
the biggest sports leagues in the world
have officially endorsed it right we did
a
landmark deal with the nfl this year
we've been partnered up with the mbas
playoffs this year were four times what
we saw last year
and the most important thing is we're
bringing the black market into a safe
and regulated environment which is great
for consumers but it also is great for
the state
because they're getting the benefit of
the tax as well
so do you think that it's
now this new wave of fan engagement that
sports betting has created we're
absolutely seeing that convergence
between
sports media and sports betting from a
viewership perspective
the stats are really compelling as well
if you look at some of the data
70 to 80 percent of consumers are more
likely to watch the game if they're
actually betting on the game
we are in the early innings
so if you look at the more mature
markets like australia and as you said
uk and ireland uh
they're probably 15 to 16 of the adult
population whereas here it's more like
seven or eight percent right so there's
there's still a lot of runway here
industry experts feel that the us is
still in its infancy when it comes to
the market of sports betting
and with 20 states still yet to dip
their toes into the market the future
growth of the industry could be
exponential
you